"The Suicide Squad" is the first DC film from
James Gunn, and it's overflowing with darkly
disturbed heroes, visually stunning sequences,
and sizzling dialogue. Here are some lines in "The
Suicide Squad" that mean more than you might
have realized the first time you heard them.
When Amanda Waller introduces
Robert DuBois, aka Bloodsport,
these are the bona fides that she
chooses to highlight on his resume:
"He's in prison for putting Superman
in the ICU with a kryptonite bullet."
This line has three purposes. First and
foremost, it establishes that although
DuBois doesn't have any superpowers, he
possesses a skillset formidable enough
to take down anyone, even arguably the
most powerful hero in all of comic-dom.
Secondly, it tells us this threat is
rooted in not only stellar marksmanship,
but also his high-tech suit and weaponry that
manifests itself, ensuring that he always
has the right weapon for any given situation.
The third purpose is to establish the stakes for
the film's biggest showdown. Near the end of the
film, as Jotunheim is collapsing and Peacemaker
is moments away from executing Ratcatcher II,
DuBois comically surfs from floor to floor, each
collapsing beneath him as he tries to stay steady
— depositing him right into the confrontation.
Realizing the situation, Peacemaker turns his gun
on Bloodsport — and if you don't immediately know
who's going to win that shootout, you weren't
listening very closely to Waller's introduction.
"Each member was chosen for his or her
own completely unique set of abilities."
Another line from Waller, and this time the
director of A.R.G.U.S. seems to be tipping
off not only her own status as puppet
master, but also a game plan that stacks
the deck against the majority of Task Force X.
Most literally, the line foreshadows a comical,
bloody opening that kills off several
characters. Why would Waller choose
Blackguard, Captain Boomerang, TDK,
Javelin, Mongal, and Savant to storm
a beach filled with armed-to-the-teeth soldiers?
None of these "chosen" fighters are bulletproof,
or have powers that could unarm the
soldiers with the wave of a hand.
They are little more than bait on a hook, selected
to make a whole bunch of noise and not much
else. It's also very hard to believe that someone
as thorough as Waller would select Weasel and
not know perfectly well that he couldn't swim.
It's just a distraction, of course — which is
interesting, not only because Waller clearly
wanted Bloodsport, Peacemaker, King Shark,
Ratcatcher II, and Polka-Dot Man to be her "A"
team, but also because by placing Colonel Rick
Flag and Harley Quinn on her "B" team, was she
hoping for them to also be mowed down in a hail
of gunfire upon reaching the shores of Corto
Maltese? Waller is surprised to learn that Flag
survived the slaughter, and doesn't seem to have
plans for Harley Quinn beyond the beach, either.
So in essence, that line is Waller
saying: "Everybody whose unique set
of abilities we need will be on the 'A' team.
Everybody chosen for useless powers that will
distract the enemy are on the 'B' team, and
they'll make a big ruckus before they die."
Now, if you were to ask Harley Quinn after the
events of the movie, she'd tell you that Javelin
did serve a purpose — and that purpose was to give
her the weapon she would eventually need to stop
Starro and save the day.
"We're all gonna die."
"I hope so."
This early moment from Abner Krill — whose
page-bound predecessor James Gunn endearingly
describes as "the dumbest DC character
of all time" — reminds us of what Gunn
does better than any modern filmmaker: Take
an idea that sounds terrible and delicately
transform it into something audiences will love.
By the end of the film, Polka-Dot Man will likely
be your favorite "Suicide Squad" member. Also
by the end of the film, he will have come a
long way from the self-loathing Debbie Downer
wishing death upon himself and his Squad-mates.
Krill has more issues than Sports Illustrated,
to be sure — chief among them a deep hatred
for the mother he envisions as every enemy he
hopes to obliterate — but as the film goes on,
he finds true joy through the
mission and the camaraderie therein.
This particularly feels true with Polka-Dot
Man's moment on the dance floor just before
the team captures the Thinker, when he seems
to let his hair down for the first time.
Another factor of growth seems to be a
genuine friendship with Ratcatcher II, who
is also the most bothered by his eventual fate.
When all is said and done, Polka-Dot Man is as
into his job as any of us in the audience who hope
to live vicariously through these characters.
"I'm a superhero!"
"Starfish is a slang term for butthole.
Think there's any connection?"
"No."
Yeah, it's a funny line. Yeah, it's
very James Gunn, and yeah, it got a big laugh in
the trailer. But it's also a totally fake moment.
As we learn later in the film, Peacemaker
was the only member of the Suicide Squad who
got the "real" briefing on this
mission. With that knowledge,
how can this exchange be seen as
anything other than a duplicitous
attempt to establish Peacemaker as too
lunkheaded to have an ulterior motive?
He already knows he's really going to Corto
Maltese to destroy files linking the U.S. to
Jotunheim and kill any of his teammates who get
in the way; he also likely knows that "Project
Starfish" refers to a giant space starfish that
has been experimented on there for decades.
Of course, this also means Waller is faking her
frustration with his question — she knows quite
well that Peacemaker's overzealous note-taking
is a façade, one quite likely devised by her.
In reality, James Gunn told Cena on the set
to play the character like "a bro'd up version
of Captain America." By the end of the film,
it's clear that Peacemaker isn't this stupid,
and also that he's arguably the most
villainous of all these villains.
In the DC Extended Universe,
there's no such thing as COVID-19. Lucky them;
all they have to fear are brain-sucking starfish,
child-murdering weasels, and walking sharks
that might mistake them for a "num-num."
As all of us are well too aware, "The
Suicide Squad" is among the many,
many blockbuster films impacted by the worldwide
pandemic that put much of pop culture on hold
(for good reason) beginning in 2020. Much of the
film was edited at the writer-director's home in
the latter half of 2020, as coronavirus forced
many people to work remotely. Of course, James
Gunn knows all this — and in his own sly way, he
wants to acknowledge the elephant in the room.
So, on the verge of the climactic battle
in Jotunheim, when the Squad briefs the
Thinker on the rules of engagement, Harley
Quinn plays comic relief, telling the mad
scientist which actions will get him killed.
"If you cough without covering your mouth—"
"Harley! Although, that isn't an open invitation
for you to cough without covering your mouth."
So if you plan to see "The Suicide Squad" in
theaters, take it from Harley Quinn and Colonel
Flag and be mindful of germ-spreading. Wash
your hands, wear your mask where applicable,
and try not to cough while Task Force X
are explaining the rules. Because we all
know now what happens to the Thinker — and you
definitely do not want to end up like that guy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
The Suicide Squad are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.